now look we're buddies we really are
buddies and he tells me everything he
told me and some things I want to hear
and some things I don't
some things are just too much like he
came home excited one night and he was
like hey I better ask you a couple
questions
I might make comfortable and I was like
did you not want to ask a friend there's
like no dad you because you know I don't
want to ask him I get embarrassed I'm
okay
he was okay so okay so you know point
out the Ashley up Friday and we're gonna
be alone together we're gonna be doing
some things I've never done before so I
just got a couple questions he goes
we're gonna be kissing and my eyes are
gonna be shut right I go yes don't be
creepy open I kiss a guy that's for
worse you know when you're kissing
somebody and you crack your eye like
this and they're like this and you're
like well [ __ ] tonight's the night I die
I guess I don't know why you'd be
staring at me from an 8 the bench away
you psycho okay I go yeah dude eyes eyes
definitely definitely close he was good
question number one answered and he goes
you know might know what to do here and
he's brought his problem was terrible
but I didn't want to tell him how to
undo a bra cuz I got high school not
knowing how to undo a bra you've got to
figure it out yourself look guys when I
want to see boobs in high school my bra
move is this you know any boob number
you put it on top of the titties and it
like cuts him in half you're like are
those
sound like a man who's you know I know
what to do it I know and then he goes
and then dad and he starts to do this
and he's looking right at me he goes and
then dad and I'm like oh I knew I should
have gotten behind for this guy Reza
walking his fingers down his stomach
then he goes then dad this is exactly
what he said he was then dad this this
is where I hear things get a little
tricky yeah whoever told you that was
right they do again it does he said you
know because oh the lights are on my
eyes are gonna be closed so I don't how
do you like when you have dad how do you
like when you like dad oh he was let me
start over okay kissing eyes closed
boobies know what to do there take a
walk down the tricky town here we are
and he said what I need to know from you
dad is went like when you're like when
you were with dad would you
this is this is getting kind of weird is
it me I do I should do we're so far past
awkward I am on suicide watch can you
just ask me the question okay that I'll
ask you like when you're doing it when
you're how would you how do you touch a
woman's Bonanno dad how do you do that
and I was like you tell you my secrets
I'm not giving you my secrets
I work no secrets every man in America
we all Harbor those secrets right there
but every man of America's couple of the
gates even gonna kick you to the finish
line
[ __ ] you figured out let the rest of us
go but you don't go from a princess to
sorcerer in one day that's our life Sam
pretty sure it's like Harry Potter seven
movies I don't [ __ ] know eight mother
I'm just saying the first time I went
down the girls pants it would have been
nice if somebody had told me but nobody
ever told me but would have a nice the
first time I haven't down a girl's pants
if somebody had told me that the hole
was so far back I was push it around
here for like 20 minutes I'm like what's
the deal is it gonna pop open or do I
need a password for this little pig
little pig let me in and then when I
finally hit a hole I thought I'm so far
back I'm in the wrong one for sure
I skipped over the vagina
and then when I realized that was in the
right place teenage boys are the worst
when I finally realized that was in the
right place I just left my finger there
like I was taking her temperature or
something no movement or anything just
this the whole time like [ __ ] the
Thanksgiving turkey and I was just
waiting harder I think I might even a
lead in it was like does that feel good
so bad
[Music]
you